I'm telling you for those that seek the
opportunity in what's happening right
now you will find it because of course
you get what you look for eight or nine
days before stuff started getting
mandated to have people working from
home we had our whole staff working from
home just understanding that social
distancing of course is going to be the
most powerful thing that you can do so
we moved on that early so we've got
everybody working from home now it's
just about you know finding that
opportunity so for sure in a lot of this
I think that it could end up being
beneficial right you've got more people
at home you've got more people seeking
contact you're gonna have people that
really need not only positivity but
they're gonna need actual action steps
to improve their situation and so if we
can deliver on that in terms of quality
then this could actually end up being
beneficial for our business but you know
needless to say I have far bigger
concerns than that for people's
well-being
I can me is that then so like take
advantage of the situation that this
happened in just now with everybody
being at their homes and stuff for that
and gathering all that attention
everything I talk about is more
important than ever because creating
content from home right now is something
people can actually do and the reality
is is that there's such an opportunity
right now to tell people your story and
to put out content so it's always been a
Content game content is what gets people
to know who you are to them book you
right context is what leads to somebody
wanting to manage you and she like
people change people's careers and
people discover people through word of
mouth or content everybody all eight
nine thousand people in here right now
have to produce content tell your story
tell people who you are tik-tok for you
bro if you're not putting out three tic
TOCs a day I'm gonna punch you in your
beautiful face yeah I go on it I fell
off it but stop don't fall off of it use
this serendipitous moment to get on it
it is so important to keep a very strong
and centered perspective about what's
happening because I don't know whether
or not this is going to last three weeks
or three months but I am
certain that this will level out and
this will pass and life will begin again
in a new chapter and so you must keep a
perspective about the fact that we are
going through something that's highly
disruptive and scary we are going to get
through it together and it will pass and
it is important to remind yourself of
that because too many of you are writing
me and talking about how you're
ruminating and your thoughts are
catastrophizing and how afraid you are
and how on edge you are the truth of the
matter is a lot of people are about to
go out of business okay and that's just
the truth and by the way sometimes
that's a good thing sometimes that's a
good thing and I'll explain you why
sometimes that's a good thing because
there are a lot of people out there that
are not responsible business owners who
don't deserve to be in business it's and
I understand a lot of people don't want
to hear this and they're saying well Pat
give me a break that's not a nice thing
to say how could you say something like
that I'm sorry if you're not responsible
and you're not being careful with the
business and you should have been
preparing no one a rainy day is coming
when the economic expansion has been out
128 percent twenty eight months in a row
and we've never had 128 months a you're
not setting aside cash when you were
making more money than ever before you
probably don't deserve to be an
entrepreneur you probably need to go
back to being unemployed that's just a
flat truth on what's taking place and
that that part is a filtering process if
you go into the MBA right and you're
playing basketball and you see players
that would come from offseason having
gained 30 pounds and you would see their
belly being big and they're upset
because the NBA is calling on fat listen
what was your discipline during
summertime when guys were at the gym
training you were clubbing every night
and eating pizza every day no wonder no
one's gonna give you a contract quite
frankly I don't feel bad for you
because no one forced you out that
cheesecake or go eat at McDonald's so
the same applies to business
there's a second thing so let's set that
part aside I had a moment of my [ __ ]
miss let's set that aside which is
something about the truth we have to
talk about that right okay here's a
second part look number two everyone
around you
whatever lead whatever position you're
in everyone is watching your face your
eyes and your tone everybody the reason
why I'm doing these lives at this time
is because I have investors I have
employees I have offices
I have executives I have vendors I have
partners I have people from around the
world who are getting on these life who
are not asking questions they're just
getting on to see my energy they're just
getting on to see what is this guy up to
I mean even my competitors are on right
now we're not asking any questions and
they use fake things to get on these by
the way hello competitors if you're on
welcome I know some of you guys around
here I love you too just so you know
that so you get on to soak the show
poised because as a husband you need to
show poise as a mother you need to show
poise as a parent as a son as a daughter
as a father as a mother as a sibling if
you consider yourself a leader you got
to show your sub poise so if you're
running a company everybody's looking at
you to see how poised you are and if
you're panicking if you're panicking
then there's gonna be more troubles
that's gonna come around the corner for
you so so far we've covered two things
one some that are going to be gone
because it's the filtering process
number two is the poise and confidence
to know that we're going to come up with
a strategy that it's all going to work
out number three there's two things that
win today one of the things I talked
last time about relationships I want to
give a complete different angle because
today whoever's the best at building
relationships gonna have an edge over
their peers but I'm going to give you a
complete different perspective on to
other things haven't spoken about one is
a speed everything is about speed okay
what do I mean by speed speed is you
know well let's see what are we gonna do
well let's talk about that tomorrow
morning and we'll figure it out tomorrow
morning when we have a bottle no we
gotta figure out today well I don't know
yeah we got so you still it's so strange
to me that in times of crisis people are
still taking all the time in the world
as if they have the luxury of time you
don't have the luxury of time people
don't have that kind of time to go say
what we'll get back and we'll see what
we're doing no whoever's moving quickly
is going to be winning today because
speed is a big asset today very big
asset today here's the next one there
are times where there are certain areas
in your business you should never be
creative in but today the most creative
people when people keep asking me
questions how do you sell today how do
you do this today how do you do that
today look I don't know I've done I
don't know how many webinars I've done
with the guys in our company and are all
over the place and we'll just have a
meeting after meeting after meeting on
different kinds of way to create to be
creative and the most creative people
are making more sales than ever before I
don't know why hey Sheena so Paula wrote
3.1 million dollars of annuities so far
and they've never done that before how
do they do it they're being created
there's a certain method to their
madness that they're doing that's
working for them right does that mean
it's happened to everybody no it's not
happening to everybody but it's
happening to some people right it's
happening to some people that they're
they're able to be creative for
themselves oh [ __ ] I just flipped this
so let me flip okay we're back at it
again so so then that's number three is
creativity today's live I wanted to talk
about a quote from Jordan Peterson which
is a mat heaven start at home and really
I started thinking about that a lot
yesterday because one of the things
that's going on right now
is that we're having like a lot of doom
and gloom scenarios being played out you
know all over the nude all over
everywhere everybody's talking about all
of these worst-case scenarios and yes
it's bad you know there's no doubt about
it we can't deny the reality of economic
impact of this we can't deny the reality
of the viral implications of this -
pandemic implications we can't deny also
the reality that we're going to be
accepting a form of martial law to a
certain degree and you know this
situation may warrant it but
unless this is a dangerous precedent to
set where the police are going to be
enforcing keeping us in our home so
there's a lot of things that seem really
challenging if you look at it from that
way but that's all focusing on the
negative and what I'm really got curious
about yesterday is like how do you focus
on the positive how do you focus on what
the heaven could be on the other side of
this or even maybe during this or
through this maybe this is the new
normal like how do you aim in heaven and
then how do you start at home so those
were the really interesting questions
that I started to ponder and you know
there are so many more a
disproportionate amount of dystopian
novels so novels that describe a
dystopian reality or movies to describe
a dystopian reality I mean Cormac
McCarthy's the road was one of the best
ones that I've ever read I mean there's
countless amounts obviously all the
Orwell novels you know Fahrenheit 451
you know Animal Farm whatever the you
want like in any different cases all
these dystopian realities even all these
zombie apocalypse you know there's a
million of those different things that
will come up but where are the utopian
you know novels and now when you think
about that you can think about Aldous
Huxley's Island right you can think
about star Hawks the fifth sacred thing
and they're creating these societies
that are living by principles that
really call out and and in some way like
inspire us to live better even let's say
avatar for example right like as Jake
goes in with the Navi people and and you
start to see the way they live that
becomes this kind of utopian society
this beautiful connected spiritual like
warrior but kind like this it's all of
the virtues that we're looking for but
in all of those cases the what
everybody's doing is they're creating a
regressive utopia so it's like taking a
much simpler puzzle and then applying
principles to that simpler puzzle and
then
so I was thinking like well how do you
create that for the complicated global
game that we have now and I don't have
all the answers to that you know by any
means but I think that's what you know
that's what aiming at heaven really is
it's like painting the picture and the
story in our minds of what it could look
like in our real world because we can
always play this fantasy game and go
back to another world with much simpler
rules and fewer people in an island
somewhere or in a bunker somewhere and
some other different you know different
location that's regressive but what
about a progressive you know future that
exemplifies you know the modern Zion or
the modern Xanadu or the modern you know
whatever this kind of utopian vision
that we might have looks like like how
do we create that and then also you know
maybe we don't need to go all of us need
to go full macro but how do we look that
look at that in our lives so that's the
start at home part like how do we start
to bring that vision into our own lives
you know by starting at home starting
with us you know and and figure out what
that means like what's the vision for
our family what's the vision for your
relationship is it a relationship where
you're communicating truthfully and
listening to each other and is it what's
the relationship with your kids what's
the what's the infrastructure where do
you live what are you doing what how are
you growing what are you what is your
dedication and your commitment to your
personal growth or your nutrition or
your fitness or your you know your
mindset or any aspect of your lifestyle
like what does that look like what is
your own personal heaven look like you
know and then I think that's the place
where we all have to start because if
we're gonna have this global macro view
of what this utopian you know vision
might look like which i think is great
to aim for aim as big as possible but we
got to start at home we got to start
with us because we gotta be that example
you know we got to be that example of
what we're trying to exemplify in the
macros if you want more advice wisdom
guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there
to me I hope you find it valuable
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I think the movie The Matrix is the
perfect metaphor for the human
experience